si vous devez faire un programme
politique qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
changer là maintenant tout de suite
d'après-vous cabinet tiennent le vrai et
programme idéal mois pendant la réponse
allait dans la démocratie et donc le
fait que ce que moi qu'elle y etienne
étudiante de 23 ans pense a finalement
assez peu d'intérêt par contre quel 150
citoyens et citoyennes tirés au sort qui
sont posé la question pendant plusieurs
mois c'était la fameuse convention
citoyenne pour le climat qui ont
auditionné tout un tas des spas
d'experts est d'ailleurs pas que des
membres du giec et où valérie masson
delmotte et puis aussi le président d'un
grand groupe d'agro industrie et ils ont
ensuite fait des débats démocratiques et
sont parvenus à 149 mesure que la france
pourra mettre en place dès aujourd'hui
pour limiter les émissions d'au moins
40% d'ici 2030 et astérix importante
sans laisser personne derrière c'est à
dire vraiment dans une logique de
justice sociale donc moi si je devais
être à leur place déjà je respecterai
ces mesures-là chisinau grèce connaît on
les a tous oublié par exemple mais je
vous invite à aller voir le site
embrasser assez intéressant et ça montre
bien aussi l'intelligence collective
parce qu'il y en avait qui étaient même
climato sceptiques au début ils ont été
tirés au sort donc c'est pas que des
militants et les mesures sont finalement
assez ambitieuse il ya par exemple
l'interdiction des publicités sur les
produits polluants pourra arrêter de
dire que c'est les gens qui décident de
même d'acheter des choses et que donc la
responsabilité est individuelle
ban en réalité quand on dépense des
millions d'euros en marketing et en
publicité pour créer le désir clairement
le choix il est dirigé donc par exemple
c'est ça ou c'est mettre dans toutes les
cantines que dans toutes les
collectivités et ben un menu une options
végétariennes sera simplement une option
sur le volet transport aérien qui a
limité les vols à interdire les vols
intérieurs qu'un alternative en train de
moins d'émissions que c'était 2 ou 4 à
285 en mieux les trains mais ce qui est
vraiment pas très long enfin je veux
dire un moment donné si on lui dans une
urgence telle qu'on n'est pas capable de
prendre en 32 heures en ont donné qu'une
question fondamentale de de mode de vie
occidental à se poser aussi
[Musique]